now from there the final question is
well now over the whole two years after
growing 15% for one year and eight
percent the second once the percentage
change when you think about the whole
period of time so I'm going to write
down the center okay so how's this gonna
come about this is how much that changes
this is in fact almost identical to how
about the absolute error to percentage
error when we're doing that in measured
earlier so here's my if you like like
absolute change how much I think look
increased and to turn that into a
percentage you compare it to my original
amount
I say well 2400 that's where I began now
here's a question for you here's a
question for you am I supposed to use
2400 or I supposed to use mister this is
a legit question right and this is the
reason why I'm finally pausing here is
this is confusing for people
okay so often the psyche if you're
following on with your working I want
you to I want to give you a piece of
argument that will help you see this is
the correct way you want to go off the
original amount not like what your final
mentally is well I can't look so pause
for a second remember how I said to you
like this line and this line they kind
of taking two lines of working and cram
them to one right do you remember that
but if you go back to where we did them
separately if I said okay what's the
change but this is just doing the slow
way and working out the change first and
then adding it
what's the change in the first year how
can work that out just the change I'm
still don't have the 2400 and yeah I'm
not going to include that 100 extra
right so this is just the change so what
is this in words right environments that
change the absolute like in dollar
amount the change it is your original
amount times your percentage change does
that make sense
this is really worth playing because it
will be the justification for why this
is the way it is so I've got the
original amount and are multiplying it
by the percentage change okay you see
how I've done is the change is 15
percent so in order to work out the
actual change in dollars I multiply now
do you see I'm only one step away from
turning that red line into this one if I
now ask the question you reverse and not
ask for can you tell me how much money I
add but what the percentage changes what
I do to this line to both sides of the
equation to turn it into this level look
carefully I'm trying to solve for like
this is my X I want to have this equal
something what do i do Tibetans have to
divide by something right I have to
divide by two thousand four hundred the
original amount let me write it down for
you right if I divide this by the
original this is an equation so you
divide the link inside you better divide
the right-hand side but look what's
happening I know you saw waiting that
kind of thing that's because I don't
want to get lost in algebra these are
all just still numbers right you can see
on the right-hand side what happens to
this fraction it cancels right you see
that so now we're like already the
percentage change that's all this left
over there on the right hand side is the
change in dollars
since / not the new amount it's not the
new method fine but it's the original
and that's why that's this number 2400
this is a source of confusion for many
students and even to us tonight which
are my supposed to compare with it some
original
do I have a number can I get a decimal
okay so this is going to hand you the
calculator says you're put to check a
what you say I like to actually show
luck this is a decimal and I'm going to
cover that as a percentage so then I
multiply which is fine well I just I
like to write that to show that sir last
thing I want to mention and this is
weird okay what were the two years how
much growth was there over the two years
there was in the first year fifteen
percent second year eight percent
fifteen plus eight percent is 23 percent
but that's not the answer I got at the
end why not because this second year
right that 8 percent that you got added
on it's 8 percent of something bigger
than what you started so that's why it
ends up being extra large and that's the
way compound it just works
it's also why it's be kind of unit but
if you start with like say if you start
with this amount right and in the first
year you have a 10% increase and then in
the second you have a 10% decrease even
though the percentages are the same you
don't end up with the same amount to end
up with less would you end up with more
we don't need to guess we don't need to
guess 2400 let's do this alone one here
what do we multiply by a single number
to get this extra 10% 110 percent well I
multiply by for the second year to get
the decrease in each a 99% right now
hold on a second
as Maddie her inflammation I can say
these um percentages acoustic I can say
them as decimals right that's one point
one what's the question time now if you
struggle with this one your calculator
will help you but one point one times
zero point nine is zero point nine nine
is that bigger is it small it's a very
slice well no why is that why is going
up by the same percentage and going down
by the same Zinj giving me a worse off
picture ten percent i'm a bigger number
is bigger hit that right and this is the
crazy this is why it's a whole new end
here alone these are percentages right
but percentages i'm not all created
equal this 10% is to september cent of
this no bomb but this 10% is bigger
right because the number got bigger in
the first yeah okay so ten percent 10
percent you actually lose more than you
gain okay so the percentage increases a
weed idea because percentage is sort of
luck with your brain a little bit okay